>> From Library of
Congress in Washington, DC
>> Michael Oreskes: Good
Morning, and thank you very much,
and my thanks to the Library
of Congress and co chair
of this festival David Rubenstien.
I'm Mike Oreskes from
NPR news and I'm going
to be your interviewer
today, because we're really,
it's a very special day, because we
have Edwidge Danticat, the memoirs,
novelists, chronicler
of the diaspora,
and author of young
adult novels as well.
And in a second, I'm going to go
sit down, and we're going to talk,
but I do have to get a couple
of things out of the way.
First, silence your cell
phones, if you want to Tweet,
if you want to Snapchat,
that's okay,
but you got to silence
your cell phone.
Second, out of quick survey,
how many teenage girls
or younger girls are here
in the room today, please?
Stand up, we need to see you.
That's good, good we
want to see you.
Thank you.
Now, how many of you teenage
girls are younger think
that teenage girls are the most
important people in the world?
Okay, we're going to come back
to that subject in a moment,
but first, let me come over here.
As you can see, I'm in radio and
we're very good with the technology.
Welcome, welcome to the National
Book Festival, it's wonderful
to have you here, it's
wonderful to be with you.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Thank
you, it's nice to be here.
Can you here me?
Oh, great, thank you.
>> Michael Oreskes: Now, I'm
a journalist, so of course,
I don't really prepare a lot,
and I've perhaps ten minutes
of questions for our conversation.
So, this will end very
early, without you.
There are microphones on both sides
here, I can almost see this one,
I can clearly see that one.
We don't have to stand on
ceremony, we only have a half hour,
so if you have a question,
or something interesting
or provocative you'd like us to
talk about, head to that microphone
and we'll come to you, soon.
Not, you know, we don't have to
wait until the bitter end of things.
But let me start, your latest,
you latest novel, Entwine,
which could also be read, I
guess, as Entwin if you, sort of,
cover up the E. It's about two
teenage girls, teenage twins,
tell us about Isabella
and Gabrielle.
>> Edwidge Danticat: So, I started
writing Entwine when I was close
to my teenage years myself, I
started it in graduate school
and I always thought I would
write young adult's books,
and I've always been fascinated by
twins, by the mythology of twins,
by actually twins,
how they function.
So, and then I put it away, and
then I wrote Breath Eyes Memory,
which is my first novel,
which is an adult novel,
but features a young girl as
she starts at twelve and goes
through her mid twenties
in that book.
And so a couple of years ago,
my mom was sick, and I just,
for some reason came
back to Entwine.
And it's about, you know,
being connected to somebody
in this case a sister
and then having
that relationship possibly go away.
So I was going through that
period of time in my life,
it felt like a good time to go
back to Jiselle and Isabelle.
>> Michael Oreskes: So how
differently did the work seem to you
from when you started it,
to when you finished it?
That was what, ten,
fifteen years almost?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah, it felt,
it felt very different, I think,
for every writer you get,
the more you write, you know,
it gets a little bit, you get
a little bit more mature at it.
Things that seem, kind of, more
overwhelming, especially dealing
with issues like grief
when your young,
you have a very different
perspective.
Since then, I have
become a parent myself,
and my brothers had teenage
children, who I could consult
and also have two brothers
who teach high school.
So I had, sort of, access to, to
different people I could tap in
and also now different layers of
experiences, not just from writing,
but about life experiences
to draw from.
So it felt very different even
though, I think, having started it
when closer to being a teenager
myself was very helpful.
>> Michael Oreskes: And,
you did have a pair of twins
who you were also able
to consult for this book?
>> Edwidge Danticat:
Yeah, I had a couple of,
my brother has younger twins,
and then I, I have friend,
a good friend who had
teenage twin daughters.
And it's very hard because fat
elements to the book to then to,
you know, to confront them with
the subject matter, but I also,
you know, I spent a lot of time
observing them and how they function
and I borrowed a lot of
things from them, for example,
when we would all, I would often
go out to dinner with them,
or I would be over to their house
[inaudible] parents, always,
the twins, in my life, the
parents would always split them
because they, if the two of
them were sitting together,
they would never, everybody else
at the table would disappear.
So the parents would make sure
they were sitting at opposite ends.
Things like that, just sort of like,
how subtle things in the family
>> Michael Oreskes: In fact sharing
that thought about the twins,
for example, being at the
opposite ends of the table,
comes up towards the
very end of the book
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah.
>> Michael Oreskes: almost
heart wrenching scene.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah,
it's in the book because,
it's the little things like that
I try to, by observing, sort of,
how the rest of the family, how the
twins fit in and also with, I think,
in Haiti and other places
in the African [inaudible]
where twins have a very, and
in African cultures as well,
twins have a very special
place in the culture
and they're certain
rituals that are done.
If one twin is no longer living
and how that, that the spirit
of that twin is carried on
and how they were maimed.
So I also wanted to incorporate
all of that, the spiritual elements
of being twins in the book.
>> Michael Oreskes: I guess we
should explain for those of you
who haven't yet had a
chance to read the book,
this book really occurs
inside the mind
and literally inside the
body of one of the two twins.
So, you've taken all this
material that you've learned
from however you've done the
research and you've created what,
at least what you believe
it would feel
like to be inside one
of these twins.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah, and, and
using the idea of twinning but also,
I think, the place I was
in my life with my mother,
transferring that also to what
it would be like to be very close
to anybody that you
loved very deeply,
that you felt was slipping away.
So the book really is from the
perspective of one of the twins
and she's also trying very
hard to recreate, to keep,
to keep another twin with
her in a very strong way, so,
it's like one story but it
tells both of their stories.
And the way that, I think
when we have a deep,
also when you have
a deep friendship,
or when we have a very deep
relationship with someone, you know,
it's said about twins, but it also
can be said about other people.
They're like, oh they finish
each others sentences,
when you have a very good friend
or someone will say something
has happened to someone
and I have a feeling, I can feel it.
Of course with twins, especially
identical twins, that's a stronger,
you know, connection but it's
also a connection, I think,
we have very much like
parents and children have,
people who've been together
for a long time have and wanted
to also explore those branches
of what a really deep loving
relationship is like even
if you're a teenager,
even if you're having,
especially since you haven't
had other ones that are
as deep in your life yet.
>> Michael Oreskes: Now,
speaking of which, as we said,
young girls figure,
and quite a number
of you are booked in
one way or another.
It's just Claire of the Sea Light,
one of your earlier
novels, wonderful book.
Who's that on the cover?
>> Edwidge Danticat:
That's my daughter Mira,
she's seven in that cover,
so we, when the book was
about to come the ninth, 2013,
and the publisher sent us a mock
up cover, and I have a friend who
said, well why don't you just,
it was a photographer
friend at the Miami Herald,
and [inaudible] he said, why
don't you put Mira on the cover,
I said well because
I don't recover it.
And he said well we can,
let's photograph her,
and you have to go either
at dawn at 5am, or like,
or at 6pm to get the right
light and we chose 6pm.
And he had her running
around and we sent
that to the publisher
and they loved it.
But I always say to people,
like, the only disadvantage
of having your daughter
on the cover is that,
if there's ever a remainder
copy, like if you walk
in to a random book
store, I have to buy it.
I can never leave that book like
for a dollar, with a dollar sticker
on it, anywhere, you know, so,
we have a lot of copies that way,
because I'm like, that's Mira, I
can't leave her here in the used,
like, bin, or the library
recycle bin, I have to get her,
I have to take her from this place.
>> Michael Oreskes: Is
there a moment, like,
maybe when she's twenty one,
when you'll turn that over to her
and tell her she has to
buy her own remainder copy?
>> Edwidge Danticat:
I think its funny,
like because when the book came out
she said, if you're in a book cover,
does that mean you're famous?
And I said, in a certain way.
And she said, does
that mean I can hang
out with Lebron James
and president Obama?
So I think she'll be picking
up her own copy [inaudible].
>> Michael Oreskes: Well they'll
be along in just a few minutes.
So first of all, a reminder,
microphones here, would really love
to hear your thoughts
about the work.
But I did say I wanted to talk
a little bit about young girls,
because I think, in a way, it
brings together two threads,
two very important
threads in your work.
Obviously, you're very well known
for your chronicling of Haiti
and what went on, one of the
poorest countries in the world,
certainly one of the poorer
countries in the Americas.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Poor in
money, but rich in culture.
>> Michael Oreskes: Yes.
Thank you for that.
That is sort of where I'm going,
which is that you also write a lot
about young teenagers and girls.
And I think a lot of people
who look at development
in the world today actually
have come to the conclusion
that the most important
people in the world,
right now, are teenage girls.
That the difference between a
world of development and progress,
and a world of continuing
poverty is really about bringing
up these girls, about their
education, about their development,
about their independence.
And, in a sense, those
are sort of two threads
that we see coming
together a little bit.
And I wondered if you could
talk a little bit about the way
in which Haiti and your insights
about Haiti sort of moved
from foreground to
background in your work.
In some cases, like in
this book, it's present,
but perhaps not the driving
element, or maybe it is.
In some others, it's
clearly the core of the work.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Well,
it's interesting that you said,
because a couple of years
ago, right before Claire
of the Sea Light came out, I worked
on a documentary called Girl Rising,
about 9 young girls from different
countries around the world,
and there was one young
girl from Haiti.
>> Michael Oreskes: Wadley.
>> Edwidge Danticat: And how
after the earthquake, Wadley, yes,
and who was trying very hard after
the earthquake to get an education.
And there were other girls
from Egypt, from Afghanistan,
and that's one of the things
that you said that was concluded,
was the reason for
making the documentary,
that once you educate young women.
You know, there are a lot of trouble
with boys, also, in these countries.
But once, one of the, the education
of women was always lagging behind,
because if people had to choose
between educating their daughters
and their sons, they would put that
investment into their sons instead
of their daughters, because
they needed to stay at home
to take care of other siblings.
So that, for me, consolidated
that very much like the importance
of educating young girls.
And so working with the book and
with Wadley on the documentary
at the same time was very important.
I think girlhood, especially black
girlhood, wether it's in the US
or it's in places around the world,
is so often misunderstood, you know?
And often a lot of our children
don't get like a long moment
of innocence, you know,
in the developing world.
Like you can have a 7 year old
taking care of a baby in the house
and working in the market.
So that moment is so quick
that one of the things, like,
obviously the girls that are
entwined are a lot more privileged
or sort of first generation,
second generation at this point,
and their childhood is
very different than Claire,
in Claire of the Sea Light.
But that's something that's always
fascinated me, because I came here
as a young girl, at 12, that the
idea of exploring girlhood and all
of it's layers and all of it's
challenges, whether you're having,
whether they're privileged
like the twins in the book,
or less privileged, struggling
like Claire in the book,
whose father is basically
deciding, because her mother died
in childbirth, her father is
deciding whether he should keep her
or give her away to somebody
else, which is a very tough choice
that a lot of parents have
to make around the world,
especially with their girl children.
>> Michael Oreskes: Yeah, and
in Claire of the Sea Light,
she actually, which by the
way, is her name, her actual.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah.
Claire. Yeah.
>> Michael Oreskes: Yeah.
You see her, actually, at the
age of 7 actually playing,
wrestling with her own father's
decisions and sort of trying
to think it through as if
she were an adult herself,
or at least trying to be.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah, which
is, I mean, we explored a little bit
of that in Girl Rising, and but it's
such a reality for so many families
who have to make this choice
whether, if I keep you with me,
there's a struggle, but if I
maybe put you in another family,
or give you to someone who's
better off, maybe they'll send you
to school, maybe, I mean,
usually it turns out badly,
where the child works like,
you know, like an adult
and doesn't get what's promised.
But that's the choice that Claire's
father is wrestling with and hoping
for a better outcome,
because he's a fisherman
and he's thinking what if I die?
And she's everything I have.
And he wants to, it's a
very big personal sacrifice,
but it's very familiar in
places like where we come from.
>> Michael Oreskes: And a very
moving book, I have to say.
Do I have question over here?
Please.
>> Hello, can you hear me?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yes.
Hi.
>> Hi. It's such a
pleasure to meet you.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Thank you.
>> And my question is,
I am a pursuing author.
>> Edwidge Danticat:
Just say you're a writer.
>> Well, and I haven't quite gotten
started, but I am in the process
but I have been doodling in my book.
And I do want to cater
to the demographics
that you're catering to,
which are the teenage girls,
and then just teenagers in general.
Because like you said, we
have issues on both sides.
But, however, I'm trying
to find out,
where is a good place
for me to start?
Because I'm noticing that
I have a lot of good ideas,
but they're dealing with
kids and their parents,
issues in the household,
because they bring them to school
and then the teacher has to kind
of like peel the layers back,
and then we can go to the lesson.
So I'm looking for some kind of tip,
one for new writers, and then, too,
how long do you think
a book should be?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Well, I
think, I think you should star
by owning it, right, like
if you want to be a writer.
And the great thing about writing
is that it's like I've worked
in film making, if you have to
make a scene, you have to have
like all of these people.
The writing, you just need your
pen and paper to begin, right?
That's one of the advantages of it.
And then, in terms of just
choosing your subject.
What you feel like your
most passionate about.
Because often we can be in
a book for, you know, for,
some people can write a
book in a couple of months,
but it can take you years.
So you may as well love the
subject, it may as well be something
that you are passionate
about, you know,
that haunts you, that
you can't forget.
Like something that you're going
to look forward to working on.
And if that, the subjects you
mentioned, if those are the things
that bother you, like you
want to get out of you,
I would do those subjects.
And how long a book
can be, it all depends.
You know? Like Their
Eyes Were Watching God,
Zora Neale Hurston's book,
it's a relatively short book,
but it has so much in it.
You know? So I always think like,
a book will be how long it wants
to be, like how long it needs to be.
So you write, whether you're an
outliner, or whether you're a person
who just writes, and then
see where it leads you.
But don't worry so much
about the length, you know.
You worry about the content
and the book will be
however long it needs to be.
>> Michael Oreskes: When you, when
you're writing, she used the word,
the phrase cater to the audience.
Who do you think about
when you're writing?
Do you think about a specific
reader, groups of readers?
No readers at all?
The story?
>> Edwidge Danticat: I think of
the girl I was when I was 15.
And what I was looking
for, what I wanted to read.
You know, there's a very
famous Toni Morrison quote,
like if there's a book you
want to read, you write it.
So that's what I always
try to do with each book,
like I write a book
that I want to read.
>> Michael Oreskes: I've tried
that, it hasn't come out yet.
So I want to ask you about that 15
year old girl, but before we do,
let's take another
question over here.
>> Hi.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Hello.
>> Thank you so much for being here.
I'm married into a Haitian
family, and I love your books.
[ Speaks in foreign language ]
And I just wanted to ask,
you write both non fiction,
as well as fiction, and how
is your process different
between the two genres?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Okay, so
between non fiction and fiction,
I feel like non fiction is more,
for me it's a more urgent process.
So I wrote a memoir called
brother I'm dying, after my uncle,
who died in immigration
custody in 2004.
So I, people will say well, why
didn't you write that as fiction?
I felt like there was, I had such
an urgent need to tell that story,
that to me that's how it came out.
My next book will be a kind of
memoir craft book by Gray Wolf Press
on my mother's, it's sort of how
writers have written about death,
but also includes some
personal reflections.
And so that also came out
of like my urgent grieving.
Right? So I feel like with non
fiction it's to me, more immediate,
because the story already exists
and what you're putting
together is the structure, right?
You're choosing the structure.
How do I tell the story?
Because the piece is already there,
the story's already happened,
so with the non fiction
it's the how.
But with the fiction it's
out of whole cloth, right,
you're inventing something.
And that takes me a little longer.
To live with the subject, to, for
the people to show themselves to me,
as Alice Walker says at the
end of the Color Purple,
she thinks the character's
[inaudible].
So I feel like with fiction it's a
longer, sort of midwifing process.
And, but with fiction I usually
end up writing my non fiction
because it feels urgent, like
I have to get it out sooner.
>> Michael Oreskes:
Although one of the things
that I think is fascinating,
if I can share a little story
from when we said hello
just before, you said,
so how do I get the
news guy [inaudible].
>> Edwidge Danticat:
That's kind of the news.
>> Michael Oreskes: One thing that
I find remarkable in your work,
though, is how, whether
it's fiction or non fiction,
it's used very significant
to the news.
Maybe not as, I mean, you're
right, the difference of immediacy,
but so many of your characters
are living in the events
that world is going
through right now.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah.
>> Michael Oreskes: And
that seems important.
>> Edwidge Danticat: And
that's part of the haunting
like when I was starting write about
what haunts you, because, to me,
if something is just like I can't
forget it and it's also a way
of engaging in the world.
And, in nonfiction, the
turnaround is quicker especially
with the essays and the offense
if you're reacting to something.
>> Michael Oreskes: You're often
described as the chronicler
or memoirist of the
Haitian diaspora.
One of the things about the world
right now is that we're, in a sense,
living in an era of Diasporas
whether Syrians or most of Africa
or Haiti or Mexico, Latin
America, there are people
in motion all over the world.
Do, and of course, immigration
has become a huge subject
in the presidential debate here in
the United States and in Europe.
What is it that you would want all
of us to understand about migration,
immigration, diaspora, that might
help people grasp this here a
little better.
>> Well, you know, we
have right now the most,
the largest population
of people in motion.
That's, since they've been counting,
something like 65 million people
in motion around the
world right now.
And, half of them are children.
And, I think, what we need
to remember is that each
of these people is an individual.
And, like, nobody leaves,
nobody would put themselves
or their small child
on a boat knowing
that they might die
unless they were urged to,
or travel across all these
countries or on a train.
Small children, we had one summer
where all these small
children were coming.
And recently, just very recently,
the Obama Administration decided
to start deportation
back to Haiti again
in the middle of a Cholera epidemic.
I think, when we hear these,
we hear blocks of numbers.
You hear 65 million people.
But, I think it's important
to imagine that's 65 million
individuals, each of them a story.
You know, they're more
than refugees,
they're more than migrants,
they're people.
And, I think sometimes, when you
talk about these boarders and walls
and so much forth, it sounds
like a plague, like we forget
that we're talking about lives,
people who are just like,
just like each of us individually.
>> Michael Oreskes: Do
I have another question?
Over here I think.
>> Yes, thank you.
You mentioned earlier that black
girlhood is often misunderstood,
which I think is so true.
What are messages that you
hope to convey to your readers
about black girlhood, regardless
of the origins of the young women?
But, what are some important
things that you hope to communicate
and some misunderstandings you hope
to address about black girlhood?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Well, I think,
one of the things, we're lucky to be
in this space and time too where
we've had wonderful authors
like Jacqueline Woodson who,
her, especially her new book,
Another Brooklyn, like all her work,
but her new book Another Brooklyn
that talks about, in part, of that.
But, in my time, we had, basically
we had Maya Angelou I Know Why the
Caged Bird Sings, and we had the
[inaudible] books, that's who,
you know, I had a few
books like that.
But now, there are a lot more books.
What I want and would love people to
understand is the many layers of it,
you know, the many
layers of black girlhood.
Because, often, I think,
in the general cultures portray this
sort of, like mini women, you know,
it's sort of the, and the whole
oversexualization [assumed
spelling], you know either
like whatever they, you know,
is projected on black women
in general is transferred
to black girls.
And so, I think, again, we're
lucky to have these authors
that write all these layers.
But, I think it's important.
What I try to do in my work and I
feel it's part of a course to add
to like that there are many ways
to be a black girl
especially in this era.
You know, black girl's code, black
girl's scientists, black girls rule,
black girls rock, black girls
mad, black girl magic, you know.
And, the fact that we even need
something like that shows sort
of how misinterpreted
black girls are.
And, as a mother of two
black girls, you know, I,
it's I'm even more invested in
that perception of showing us
as many layers in many
different ways.
>> Michael Oreskes: I'm
going to come back then
to the question of
you as a teenager.
You arrived in America when
you were 12, the United States.
And, at that point you spoke
very little if any English.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah.
>> Michael Oreskes: Yeah.
And so, English is really
your third language.
And yet you write mostly in English.
Is that right?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah.
>> Michael Oreskes: so, Samuel
Becket once explained that he wrote
in French much of his work
including Waiting for Godot and some
of his other work because
it gave him better control
and distance from his work.
What's the reason you have
chosen to write in English?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Well, I write
in English because I came at 12
and it's just kind of
flowed into English.
I think, maybe if I were older
when I got here it would've
been a more difficult choice.
But it's, I always said to people if
I, I think if we're going to a place
where they speak Spanish,
I'd be writing in Spanish.
It's just kind of, and, but I,
I did find that when I
started writing initially
that English was kind of like
a way to, when I would write
in my diary I would write in English
so my parents couldn't read it.
So, it was also, like even
they wouldn't understand also.
So it was a, it was a layer
removed sort of like my own space.
It was a protective space.
So it also did serve
that purpose, you know.
>> Michael Oreskes: Well
similar to Becket in ways.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Exactly yeah.
>> Michael Oreskes: French
was his third language.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Yeah.
And I've been reading, I just
was recently reading [inaudible]
who wrote, she wrote
a book in Italian
about her discovery of Italians.
And, it's really, I think writers
always want to reinvent themselves
in some way, right, if
you I think for me that's
where coughing genres come
in like going from the adult
to picture book, like you feel
like you want to be refreshed.
Right? And, language
is certainly one way.
And it becomes, I'm a little bit
relieved all the time I see my
relatives they'll be a year
before like my relatives
in Haiti will read the book.
So, I always feel like okay
they're like it'll be a year less
but they'll be mad if I
said something that they.
So, there's a kind of also
freedom in other languages
that I think like, especially
in [inaudible] book she describes
very beautifully about stepping
over boundaries that you
think you already have
and whether they're
linguistic boundaries
or they're genres boundaries,
but it just offers this
kind of freedom to it.
>> Michael Oreskes: Do your
relatives get mad very often?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Not very
often, but they always say
like why did you make me look
like that, you know, in this book.
And I, I'm always saying
it's not you.
And they never believe me.
>> Michael Oreskes:
Let's come over here,
good to have a question
on this side.
>> Good morning
>> Edwidge Danticat: Good morning.
>> How are you?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Fine thank you.
>> Good. When my daughter
was in high school,
she had to do a book
report on Haiti And,
because I helped her
proofread it I got a basic.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Just proofread?
>> Well yeah, well I got
a basic understanding
or an education on Haiti.
And, a lot of times, when
we don't live other places,
we're just concerned
about where we are.
One of the things that I
found a lot of interest
in was Haiti is a predominantly
black country.
But, they have a color issue.
So, you know, they go by the
whites, light skin, dark skin.
Had you ever thought about
doing a book about that issue?
>> Edwidge Danticat: Well, I mean,
color is certainly
not unique to Haiti.
It's a, so, if you imagine, see like
in Brazil and Haiti and other places
where we had colonialism
and in Hattie we had the
French as the Colonial power.
And there was, there was a
chart, there was something
like 300 racial categories,
right, that was just like,
so they were saying if you were a
mulatto, had a kid with an accent,
like the whole, I mean it
was like an insane chart of,
and then of course, the higher,
the lighter you were on that,
in that chart, the more privileges
you had, because you know,
some of the children of the,
of the owners of the enslaved
people would then send their kids
to friends, and then there's
a very interesting case.
There's a novel that's about to
come out by Marie Vieux-Chauvet,
it's republished, called Dance on
the Volcano where she talks about,
for example, these women, like
in the cap, and in the south,
they weren't allowed to wear their
jewelry, like their diamonds,
they were like the
mistresses of these rich guys
and they gave them jewels, and
they weren't allowed to wear them
on their, so they would
wear these loop earrings,
or they would wear their
diamonds on their toes.
You know, they would find
ways to like define the thing.
So I think, just as it is in this
country, color is, I mean, it's so,
it's part of, it's a part of
white supremacy that's very hard
to extract.
So I, I feel like, I mean it's not a
story that I want to concentrate on,
because I don't think
it's unique to us.
I mean, maybe in part of it,
sort of it's allowed with power,
it's allowed with money from
the whole colonial period.
And so it's something
that is definitely one
of the ills we suffered from.
But I think it's also
buffered in a place like Haiti,
by the fact that you have
a majority black population
and you have dark skin
presidents and you have, you know,
you've seen all these variations.
But if I, wherever it's written,
if I, I would love to read a book
on it, whether it's about
the US or about Brazil,
but that gives me more than we know.
You know? And for me, like, I
don't feel like I have that passion
for the subject that would
open a new page on it.
>> Michael Oreskes: Well, believe
it or not, the time has roared by.
We've used up all our time,
and even a little bit more.
I do want to let everybody to know
that Edwidge Danticat
will be downstairs
in a half our in room, okay, well.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Table 16.
>> Michael Oreskes: Table 16.
If you'd like a book signing.
And, I think, on behalf of
everybody here, including myself,
thank you so much for doing
this, it was wonderful.
>> Edwidge Danticat: Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as LOC.gov.